hey there is there a project you're
working on I know more than you all
right 311 well Diane for Pooles you want
to speak with public
works I understand you've tried them
four times government is inefficient and
should be dissolved please hold while I
transfer you Donna can you help me I got
a 311 call but it was all static that
sounds like an IT problem well how do I
get it here call
311 311 How can I oh hello again
Diane nobody
answered okay you know what someone will
be there
shortly Andrew get your lunch some water
and a 40 lb bag of asphalt okay boss
what are we doing we're fixing a
pothole hi I'm Andy I really like your
dress I'm a princess I'm a mermaid I'm
the director of Parks and Recreation I'm
here to fix that hole this is our
kingdom you have to ask permission
excuse me you your highnesses we do
humbly request thine permission to beix
doth holes Yonder only if you can tag us
come
here your tax dollars at
work Hey Ron good to see you weren't you
pirate last year yes this is my
Halloween costume Andrew are you aware
that your bathroom faucet is leaking are
you kidding me I just stuffed a sock and
it yesterday yesterday what else do they
want me to do there's an exposed wire
above the bathtub as well oh yeah shock
wire I call it that cuz if you take a
shower and you touch the wire you
die yes that is accurate do you have a
toolbx yeah no home is complete without
a proper toolbox here's April and
Andy's a
hammer half of a pretzel baseball card
some cartridge that says Sonic and
Hedgehog a scissor half and a
flashlight filled with jelly
beans in the time I've worked here I've
taken great pains to see as little of
this building as possible turns out the
third floor is silent empty and
completely free of government
work I can't think of anything more
beautiful to share with my
son if I had a toolbox I could take care
of that faulty
radiator this place is a paradise I
guess we could go to a pharmacy but I
really don't want to use like a cheap
plastic ring I hate to say this but Anne
Perkins has terrible taste in rings what
what is this it's a tow ring with a
brown gemstone is this a ruby that's
gone bad I am out of
ideas jewelry store no that's closed
that's why we're doing doing this
perhaps I can be of service how how much
do you think Anne would miss this scot
well I don't know it's part of her
house well okay it's not rocket science
I removed the scon fired up my
grandfather's torch heated up the pieces
in a cast iron bucket liquefy the metal
poured into a mold obviously keep it
over a low flame to achieve a nice
temper cooled it in anif freeze and just
forged and shaped the ring things any
with a crucible and a sine torch
and a cast iron waffle maker could have
done the same whole thing only took me
about 20 minutes people who buy things
are
suckers when April and Andy married I
didn't get them a wedding present in my
experience wedding presents are nothing
more than kindling on the divorce
bonfire but I think I found a way I can
really help them make a
home you bean bag come with me I'm an
eggplant I don't care come with me why I
need small
hands
I'm
scared lemonade please and thank you hey
I'm sorry if I was CT earlier I'm a
single mom and sometimes things get
chaotic around here when you shut up
from the parts department no need to
apologize I understand completely this
is delicious
well I got it from food and stuff so
that's where I got these gloves right so
how exactly are you going to fix this
hole just for my own
edification uh I dug the loose gravel
out of the hole now I'm using a
jackhammer to remove the larger pieces
then I'll spray down the hole to settle
the dust and fill it with cold patch
asphalt well thank you now I can fix the
next one
myself Ron and and sitting in a tree k i
SS I SS i p p
i you hear that bird there I think I got
it yep you got
it can you at least tell me what you're
doing I'm a homeowner I would like to
actually learn
something yeah I'm tightening the valve
stem into the valve shank I'm replacing
the handle and then tightening the set
screw which will hold it in place now
oh my God we made it work it's a good
feeling sense of accomplishment and
pride damn it I just love it so
much are you okay great I'm going to go
around this house and fix everything I
can find that needs fixing you want to
help I really do good that's
next just as we suspected John we
repaired the valve stem seal and now all
the that remains is to tighten down this
packing
nut and that should do it can we help
you no we have everything under control
my crew is redoing this whole floor
we're the only people allowed up here
right now we proceed with your work you
won't notice us at all well we're going
to be kind of
loud my son is several weeks old he's
quite familiar with the sound of power
tools he's a big
guy man forget about working I just want
to stare at this baby all day what is
the nature of your work on this floor
total redo new floors fixtures boming
how long will it take 6 to 8
weeks deal I will do all this work for
you in the time allotted just have your
tools and materials brought up here are
you crazy this is enough work for a
whole crew I'm sure the government
believed you when you told them that and
I tip my cap to you for profiting off
their ignorance but I'm offering you two
months paid vacation and the ability to
take credit for my work which will be
Flawless okay guys let's
go I got all the help I'll need right
here excuse
us ah nice form son make sure you keep a
firm pressure on the cranium on the
cranium listen up I have to turn off the
power for 1 minute we're going to go
dark people bear with us okay we got to
switch off the main fuse hose it's just
a fuse it's just a fuse people just a
fuse I'd say you got the handle on that
torque wrench yeah well the flange was a
little warped so I just goosed it with
the triple 3 bolts Mac that was nonsense
I know but it's so fun to talk like that
you know
what keep
this you earned it thanks
[Music]
Ron
Ron what are you doing here the most
important government work I've ever done
sanding rat urine stains out of this
floor what are you doing here I come
here to think sometimes by
myself but now that you're here damn it
I am going to speak to you very vaguely
about a problem that I have and you
cannot ask me any questions or details
about it that is my ideal conversation
aside from no conversation but that
feels unlikely look you know how much I
love ponie but the more I try to fix it
the more people fight me they call me
names they recall me they try to kill
the merger they literally punch me in
the face and yet every time I
contemplate leaving just walking away
once and for
all I just can't do
it what is wrong with
me yesterday I fixed that old steam
radiator threaded a new valve into the
side removed the handle from the base
unscrewed the packing nut from the stem
this subpar toolbx only had one wrench
so I was lucky it was a 3/4 or I'd have
been screwed yeah man you are lucky come
on Ron what the hell I need your help by
the time I was done this 100-year-old
piece of americanmade cast iron was
singing like a bird now to most people
this story would seem boring that's
ridiculous it's a story about a radiator
but to me it was immensely satisfying
because I enjoy fixing radiators you
like fixing this town Leslie you always
have you know it's an uphill battle but
you love the struggle I would also add
that you've already done a hell of a lot
to make this town better and people like
this young man here will benefit from
your hard work he is a beautiful boy
he's quite a looker thank you
Ron what's that
nothing Clear My
Throat
oh